[Music]
in Toronto this basketball fan like no
other I breathe drink everything about
the rafters basketball is truly my whole
life is around the Raptors see deeply
for the last 22 years I have never
missed a game a Raptors superfan my name
is na Bhatia and I'm Raptors super fan
if you've watched any Raptors games in
the last decade maybe you've noticed the
bearded man sitting courtside
well that's knob and his story starts in
India and takes him right here to Canada
fleeing violence not left and settled in
Toronto
he worked hard opened a very successful
car dealership when the city editor
named a franchise the Raptors arrived
and I bought my first two tickets I
enjoyed the game I was sharing the most
in the whole arena
the team embraced him and being a
superfan has its perks
when the legend Kobe Bryant came for his
last game to Toronto he came to me and
said super fan I want to thank you what
you have done because you have created a
culture of bringing everybody together
through this game of basketball he also
gets to hang with Canadian royalty had I
know Drake pretty well
but what's most important about a half
super fandom is that he represents the
changing face of basketball fans around
the world basketball has changed my life
tremendously it has given me an
opportunity to integrate my community
the South Asians into the mainstream not
maybe the first Raptor super fan but he
wants everyone on board I want to see
this game taking to the next level we
are all the communities everybody the
seeds the Hindus the Muslims everybody
coming to the game
[Music]
[Music]
in London Ontario there lives a man
whose basement is unlike anything you've
ever seen this is Robert ward off hi my
name is Robert ward Oh Robert has been
playing the same Dungeons & Dragons
campaign for over 30 years 35 years to
be exact I'm sorry that's okay
welcome would you like to play a Worman
robe you look like a rogue wait let's
back up for a second the Dungeons &
Dragons is a fantasy role-playing game
or a group of people come together and
play on adventures dictated by Dungeon
Master these adventures also known as
campaigns are set in the Dungeons &
Dragons world and normally have an end
point or they just fizzle out due to
people's lack of commitment but Robert
is in a league of his own and here's why
the dude has a serious collection
I think our collection of miniatures is
around 20,000 and then over the years I
discovered terrain ultimately I'm a
collector also and a lot of my enjoyment
comes from being able to get new stuff
and to put new stuff on the table so the
players are constantly coming across new
settings because it's a game that
doesn't stick to one particular campaign
setting I'm able to use any things that
actually fit the world and so it is a
long process but over 35 years you can
develop a credit collection as Roberts
collection grew so did the number of
players word began to spread about the
neverending campaign we have people
coming from all over the country to play
often flying in weight all over the
country that's right
[Music]
these are some of the people who play in
Roberts game where are you guys from
I flew in from Saskatoon Saskatchewan I
drove in from Toronto Brussels Ontario
mocha Ontario Calgary Alberta hold on
what happens if people can't fly in or
drive to Robert's house to play every
one problem so the game has always been
determined really through friendship
it's really been a way that I keep my
friends together I knew early on that if
I was able to create a game that was
good enough and that means it had to be
better than video games it had to be
better than any other game they could
find that they would keep coming no
matter where I was and so that takes
again imagination and it takes change
and it takes having a system that is
constantly dynamic that is changing that
is growing and that is constantly
getting better
[Music]
The Simpsons it's the longest-running
animated show with maybe the most
recognizable character on TV outside of
the US the show is beloved by millions
some of the biggest fans Latin Americans
or a mere course is a jewel del mundo in
Mexico City there is one man responsible
for making all marrow Simpson
funny in Spanish hello London miss you
do so Hubert obelisk Oh yuck positio not
only to cuerpo so you're made with Milo
so you're made well mono is tomato cami
okay so you melt ovalis simile ho so
young birth twins so a total of logic is
to my content to estar aqui pero es
tanto para listen don't own a calico to
a party say bo-bop-a-doozy boogy no also
see Taylor's great el habla discontent
relevant a mrs. Gita mrs. joram a
caesarean
please don't oh no comparison Keturah
Colorado Anita is the most ominous la
formación de personaje de medicines more
extractive industries no Mae Coleman
tango equals zero sorry Jules
come here Tess el mero Simpson as
impossibly during systole training less
70 and in Latin America porque de nada
is a while a Latin America so much they
went to buy is total mental institute or
[Applause]
satirical not topical estación pues
converted azo Nostrum BN t called--oh
the RZA bucho mas facil the mass
aggressive edad de los sisters the mass
explosion and la citrusy honest por
ejemplo Benia
una razón de du capitole la carga
semantics adele okay dcae era muy local
Oh Sarah
muy North America destiny a poner algo
que favorite and Escovedo como es la
parte de todo que hacer Arisa juice can
Yavin me sir in buscando mrs. carne en
contra una Fras ecclesia un amigo mio
dosa deposit its tiro de la this Amedeo
Planeta innovation is this
o menos internists and popular porque es
uno de nosotros Homer Simpson total
intenta en todo fracas are increasingly
failing charity in questa differentially
me total retail Tam O'Shanter of
reticence in $10 el primero el fracaso
come on ultima scientifica for known
persona exile in detainee nobility of
them Muharram yamaha kilo prayer Jesse
you know they're very picture 1914 McGee
who square bar or attack concave and the
call him badly Evita was ill omen
Masha hello in the town of a deep or in
India's Gujarat state you will find a
man who is arguably Charlie Chaplin's
biggest fan
mera naam Ashok Kumar Sahni old man
Charlie Chaplin Cove Baha Baha TR car
Tommy
Charlie's Africa pehla pehla movie the
hominin gold rush or younger Apple Apple
of Gotha whose poster karate but the
picture of 20 Charlie something he's a
funny picture taking Tom on deck today
tell us there's a load photo yeah
baccarat seats a little Gilligan doctor
a Swami practices herbal medicine in his
village and uses Charlie Chaplin to help
treat his patients Oh
logically now after getting a son DVD be
Charlie Chaplin the account you have the
grant of mushrooms
laughter is the best medicine
[Music]
doctoral swanee isn't the only one with
a passion for mr. Chaplin
he started the Charlie Circle in 1973 to
honor and remember one of the world's
greatest comedians Charlie Chaplin is
beloved because of his everyman attitude
and comedy that brought joy to the
masses I'll be Holly Muhammad Ali said
you can just the second I get it
dr. Rubin on a theme song every year the
Charlie Circle celebrates Charlie
Chaplin with a parade singing dancing
and of course cake I want to keep him
alive till I'm alive
and then my grandsons my friends and all
these fellows will keep him alive
because of his marvelous acting without
saying in a wash to that public yellow
mustache yellow hair the big green eyes
he's Bernie brewer the Milwaukee Brewers
mask
[Music]
Brittney's the heart and soul of the
Brewers but who is Bernie he's actually
based on Milton Mason a real-life
Brewers fanatic in the late 1970s a 69
year-old Mason decided that he had
perched himself on top of the stadium
scoreboard he vowed not to come down
until crowd of at least 40,000 people
came to see a Brewers game a little over
a month later 44,000 387 people filled
the stadium and Milt now a hero came
down from his perch a few years later in
1973 Bernie brewer became the official
mascot of Milwaukee Brewers just like
Milt Mason Bernie knew how to make an
entrance
he first emerged from a beer barreled
chalet and after every home run he would
slide down from his perch into a beer
stein sadly in 1984 the Brewers tore
down Bernie's perch and pushed him into
retirement that didn't last long whoever
and in 1993 Brewers fans voted and
brought Bernie back Bernie brewer back
on a scoreboard perch has no plans of
retiring anytime soon
[Applause]